[Musica]
io sono un operatore umanitario un
cooperante questo vuol dire che per
lavorare mi sposto e viaggio tanto anzi
tantissimo e vado in tutti quei paesi
colpiti da crisi emergenze dove il
nostro intervento il nostro lavoro
appunto umanitario può portare un
miglioramento alle condizioni di vita
delle persone un aiuto e un supporto
concreto
come tutto questo viaggiare a giro per
il mondo
cerco sempre di crearmi la mia confort
son una zona di conforto fatte di quei
piccoli gesti quotidiani che in qualche
modo mi fanno sentire a casa e mi fanno
stare bene
l'anno scorso ho lavorato ad haiti paese
colpito da numerose tremende crisi
umanitarie di vario genere veramente
salute alimentazione
diritti umani violati e violenze di ogni
genere significa va a lavorare ogni
giorno a contatto con la sofferenza
umana ma anche in un contesto del genere
così drammatico così tremendo piano
piano sono riuscito a crearmi la mia
zona di conforto
ho avuto la fortuna di vivere e lavorare
ad haiti con la mia compagna è visto che
la situazione di insicurezza del paese
non ci permetteva di fare nient'altro
che lavorare e stare in casa ci siamo
buttati sulla cucina
quella che vedete è un primo esempio di
cucire in padella vive da ridere perché
ad haiti avere un forno è considerato un
lusso sì lo so non è bella anzi non è
per niente bella non me ne voglia
lasciar presente stasera questo ted per
ora sicuro che era molto buona un
piccolo gesto ma cucina e per noi a
cucinare voleva dire questo stare bene
insieme e prenderci cura l'uno
dell'altra
gli esseri umani hanno questa
grandissima capacità di voler cercare e
ricreare i piccoli gesti della loro
quotidianità anche nei momenti peggiori
della loro vita le faccio un esempio una
signora in mano un trasportino e dentro
il suo gatto
la signora non riesce veramente a
trattenersi non resiste e baci il
trasportino come se in qualche modo quel
bacio arrivasse al suo gatto
un piccolo gesto la voglio dire una
carezza una coccola come quella che
potremmo fare a noi e ai nostri
animaletti domestici ogni giorno
se non fosse per il contesto
la signora è una rifugiata ucraina ed ha
appena attraversato a piedi il confine
con la polonia
ora riguardiamo per un attimo questa
fotografia e proviamo a immaginare il
bene e il benessere che c'è dietro
questo piccolo gesto
una persona che è scappata da casa sua
ha lasciato il suo paese
portando con sé solo le cose più
importanti e tra queste c'è il suo
gattino
c'è una sfera dei piccoli gesti che
ritengo molto più importante molto più
densa e intensa
che quella familiare ma per parlarvene
dobbiamo andare un pochino più est e
andare in ucraina alle opoli
una mamma che appoggia la sua testa a
quella di sua figlia in questa
dolcissima coccola questa dolcissima
carezza
anche questo è un gesto normalissimo
voglio dire è un gesto come una coccola
come potremmo farla noi ei nostri figli
o come quelle che noi abbiamo ricevuto
dalle nostre mamme
io ho dei bellissimi ricordi di mia
mamma che mi fate le carezze identiche
anche questo se non fosse per il
contesto
questa bambina che si chiama riina
chiamava col suo nome si chiama a riina
è scappata da kiev con sua mamma perché
come potete vedere arena è malata e le
cure oncologiche non si possono né
sospendere né tantomeno fermare e allora
la mamma ha portato a riina da da kiev
ha appena la città è stata attaccata dai
primi razzi russi alle opoli dove a meno
ha cercato di portare avanti le sue
terapie
in questo piccolo gesto
cioè tutto l'amore del mondo
c'è tutto l'amore di cui questa bambina
ha bisogno
perché vi faccio vedere una fotografia
del genere innanzitutto perché io ero lì
quando questa foto è stata scattata
sì perché c'è una cosa che ancora non vi
ho detto
io è da lì che arrivo io arrivo dall
ucraina
da mesi ormai lavoro tra la polonia e
ucraina con fondazione soleterre
soleterre ng italiana e impegnata a
garantire il benessere fisico ed emotivo
di uomini donne e bambini in italia e
nel mondo
siamo in ucraina dal 2003 dove
supportiamo istituto nazionale del
cancro denaro chirurgia e una rete di
ospedali tra leopoli e kiev in questi
anni abbiamo sopportato più di 28 mila
bambini malati di tumore
quando la guerra è scoppiata
ci siamo mossi da subito per far
evacuare i nostri piccoli pazienti
dall'ucraina all'italia passando per la
polonia attraverso quello che si chiama
ponte aereo e con questo sistema di
evacuazione sanitaria
siamo riusciti ad evitare che i nostri
piccoli pazienti passassero giorni o
settimane senza cure salvavita nei
bunker degli ospedali di kiev e di
leopoli e se ve lo state chiedendo
questo il bunker di un ospedale ucraino
siamo stati la prima o ng europea ad
attivare un sistema di evacuazione del
genere quando la guerra scoppiata
e abbiamo portato via da lì
più di cento bambini malati di tumore e
feriti di guerra
ma noi non siamo eroi e non siamo
assolutamente supereroi anzi niente di
tutto ciò noi siamo solo dei
professionisti che fanno quello che
possono del loro meglio con quello che
hanno a disposizione
quando racconta la mia famiglia ai miei
amici oa volte anche giornalisti che di
tanto in tanto mi intervistano cosa
facciamo in polonia e in ucraina
viene chiesto molto spesso ma noi da qui
cosa possiamo fare come possiamo in
qualche modo contribuire dall'italia dal
lontano e la mia risposta è sempre la
stessa ed è molto semplice con un
piccolo gesto
e questo piccolo gesto è la donazione e
adesso si è magari a qualcuno di voi può
anche pensare ecco lo sapevo
ora ci parla di soldi
niente affatto
quello che voglio farvi vedere e farmi
capire è come l'equivalente di un paio
di caffè e non stiamo parlando del caffè
presi in centro a milano in piazza duomo
è
possano effettivamente portare a tutto
questo come tanti piccoli gesti possono
veramente portare a qualcosa
l'indifferenza d'ipocrisia
ci hanno reso assuefatti alla violenza
alla sofferenza al dolore e alle notizie
orribili
insofferenza
indifferenza e ipocrisia sono i nostri
più grandi nemici e noi cerchiamo di
combatterli ogni giorno con il nostro
lavoro sul campo
io credevo che veramente un bambino con
tumore fosse la cosa più drammatica del
mondo
ma un bambino col tumore che scappa da
una guerra e la tragedia più grande di
questo mondo
e allora grazie a tutti i vostri piccoli
gesti messe insieme siamo riusciti a
fare grandi cose
ogni confezione di farmaci che abbiamo
inviato agli ospedali ucraini e anche
ogni mezzo ambulanza apparecchiatura che
abbiamo trasportato in ucraina ma poi
anche una persona che abbiamo ascoltato
supportato che abbiamo affiancato nei
campi profughi in ucraina e in polonia
e anche ogni bambino coi loro genitori
che abbiamo portato via da quell'inferno
in italia
tutto questo è stato possibile solo
grazie a tutti i vostri piccoli gesti
messi insieme
e allora
abbattiamo la tessera dell'indifferenza
e creiamo questo bellissimo effetto
domino di solidarietà
tutti i nostri piccoli gesti insieme
possono veramente cambiare il mondo
grazie di cuore
[Applauso]